voilà pour les meilleurs moments de
cette audition d'olivier ferrand qui
était donc reçu hier au sénat pour en
parler j'accueille ici il y en a c'est
si bon jour une double casquette vous
êtes présidente du groupe communiste au
sénat et bien sûr vous êtes la
rapporteure on vous a entendu dans cette
audition un mot sur les explications du
ministre qu'est ce que vous en avez
pensé on voyait une ligne de crête en
fait dans le discours le ministre réfute
totalement l'idée que la politique du
gouvernement et puis être conçu par les
cabinets privés mais on voit que
certains membres de ces cabinets
participe à l'écriture de notes ou de
documents supports dans la gestion de la
crise sanitaire ya une ligne de crête en
fait oui oui tout à fait mais c'était le
cas pour olivier ferrand mais c'était le
cas aussi il y a quelques jours pour
madame amélie de montchalin et ça l'a
été avant monsieur véran par monsieur
cédric haut on voit effectivement qu'il
ya une ligne de crête et ils ont du mal
à trouver les arguments pertinents et
juste qui pourra vous pour que vous
n'ayez coureurs exotiques et que notre
administration ait besoin de cabinet
conseil mais ils sont les uns et les
autres toujours sur la défensive
or nous savons très bien puisque nous
avons des éléments ce qu'on appelle des
livrables des bons de commande nous
savons tous les toits voulez vous les
montrer je les montre régulièrement on
sait très bien qu'il ya eu un recours
quand même exponentielle ces dernières
années au cabinet privé par par le
gouvernement alors qu'est ce que vous
leur prochain gouvernement ce que c'est
pas illégal d'avoir recours à ces
cabinets privés ça on l'a bien compris
c'est quoi le problème c'est ce flou
entre le privé et public c'est ce flou
entre le privé et le public c'est celle
de lui expliquer nouba écoutez moi je le
dis souvent je n'ai strictement rien
contre les cabinets conseils je ne suis
pas pour licencié des centaines de
personnes qui travaillent c'est pas mon
sujet après ceux qui décident des
politiques publiques dans notre pays
est-ce qu'on laisse la main à des au
privé ou est-ce que c'est notre
gouvernement l'état et notre
administration qui trace les lignes d'un
autre politique de nos politiques
publiques or on s'aperçoit que là aussi
à une ligne de crête dire qu'on passe
facilement
de l'autre côté et c'est ça que nous que
nous reprochons nous
sommes attentifs à l'utilisation de
l'argent public et à une autre question
quand même qui nous paraît essentiel
dans ce débat c'est la souveraineté
c'est celle de la souveraineté on a
entendu le président de votre commission
denquête arnaud bazin dire qu'il avait
l'impression qu'ont appris les agents
publics dans un vivier privé sans avoir
passé un marché clair sur une mission
précise avec les cabinets privés alors
est-ce que c'est lié à la crise
sanitaire où il ya eu comme ça un peu un
méli mélo dans ce qu'on demandait à ses
cabinets privés ya la crise sanitaire
effectivement mais il ya eu avant la
crise sanitaire et on s'aperçoit que ces
recours au lieu de façon je le répète
exponentielle avant la crise sanitaire
dont cannes explique pas tout je veux
dire que ce je pense que ce sont des
choix politiques qui sont faits et au
détriment de notre administration et de
notre haute administration en
particulier et c'est ça qui n'est pas
acceptable parce que je le répète il ya
bien évidemment la question
l'utilisation de l'argent public et je
suis désolé on va leur bien mais on doit
s'en préoccupe bien sûr et puis je le
répète encore la question de la
souveraineté de notre pays parlant de la
facturation des prestations de ces
cabinets de conseil car eh bien le total
ont là ça y est le chiffre 26,79
millions d'euros depuis mars 2020 pour
les prestations de conseil commandé par
le seul ministère d'attentes de la santé
1 c'est le chien qui était donné vous
avez évoqué à ce chiffre vous avez dit
on parle d'argent public sept cent mille
euros par exemple pour une personne qui
assure la coordination opérationnelle
une personne pour une tour le contrôle à
santé publique france sincèrement avez
vous ajouté vous ne trouvez pas que ça
fait un peu cher la mission c'est ça il
ya une dérive aussi dans la facturation
je pense qu'il ya effectivement une
dérive je suis désolé mais je tiens à le
répéter participer à des réunions à 9
heures et à 15 heures pour un coût
exorbitant ça interroge bien évidemment
que ça interrogé puis ça interroge sur
la nature des contrats la nature précise
des missions et ça c'est très difficile
à avoir malgré des recherches n'ont pas
y arriver vous avez donc plusieurs
ministres cette semaine on l'a vu au
delà de monsieur verront vous n'êtes pas
et cédric rouzé famille madame de
montchalin également florence par ali
pour un ministère des armées quel est
votre intuition maintenant tant que
rapporteur vous trouvez qu'elle ait des
rives là vous allez vous êtes en train
de pointer du doigt quelque chose qui
avait pas été vus attendais et je ne
veux pas conclure les travaux de la
commission denquête le lac commission
denquête soit terminé parce qu'elle est
composé de parlementaires de sénatrice
et de sénateurs de tous les groupes
politiques
nous faisons un travailleur remarquable
j'ai un sentiment mais je veux le
confronté aussi à la vie des autres
membres de cette commission denquête je
tiens beaucoup à ça je tiens beaucoup au
fait de travailler de de laisser cette
colle collégialité pluraliste s'exprimer
c'est très important j'ai un avis et je
le donnerai quand nous aurons un échange
entre commissaires de cette commission
enquête j'ai encore une question elle
concerne les potentiels conflits
d'intérêts ça a été évoqué ici et y est
aussi allé de l'audition de monsieur
véran parce qu'il a reconnu que je cite
la loi ne prévoit pas d'aller regarder
les éventuels conflits d'intérêts ou
liens d'intérêts d'une personne que vous
prendriez dans le cadre d'une mission
externe fin de citation c'est presque un
appel du pied aux législateurs lasser
oui et c'est un appel du pied mais c'est
un faux appel du pied puisque nous avons
auditionné aussi monsieur migaud le
président de la haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique et ce
n'est pas ce qu'il nous a dit donc on va
là aussi comparé creuser un peu les
éléments qui nous il ya des différends
comme il y a des différences dans la
nature des contrats qui sont passés avec
ses cabines et donc il ya encore des
choses à vérifier a vérifié à creuser et
je vais vous dire que c'est parce que
donc très rapidement quand est ce que
vous pensez rendre vos travaux nous
pensons à la campagne présidentielle
mais ça c'était prévu déjà dès le début
dès la création de la commission
denquête on envisage de rendre notre
rapport vers le 15 mai eh bien merci on
sera ça de très près senna mercier
[Musique]